[Musica]
al giorno d'oggi si parla tanto di
diversità
però per molte persone rimane ancora un
concetto astratto
Voi sapete dirmi cos'è la diversità
avete mai fatto esperienza della
diversità
Io sì e la prima volta è stata 13 anni
fa quando andavo in terza media
vedevo che avevo dei gusti e dei
sentimenti totalmente differenti dalle
mie compagne o dei miei compagni di
classe
per esempio quando le mie amiche si
ritrovavano durante l'intervallo per
parlare di ragazze io me ne stavo in
disparte
perché non mi interessava nei loro
discorsi
io volevo parlare di ragazze prima
parlavano dei ragazzi
E
immagino che voi ora vi starete
chiedendo Vabbè ma tu sei un ragazzo
è normale che tu voglia parlare di
ragazze
è vero Io sono un ragazzo però il genere
che mi hanno assegnato la nascita è
femminile Infatti sono un ragazzo trans
fino a cinque anni fa il mio aspetto era
totalmente differente rispetto a quello
che è ora per arrivare dove sono adesso
ho fatto un lungo percorso
mi sentivo diverso e venivo percepito
come diverso perché il mio orientamento
sessuale Era visto come minoritario
E perché mi dovevo sforzare per
uniformarmi al contesto in cui vivevo
mi vestivo femminile Oppure mi truccavo
non per un piacere mio personale ma
perché volevo essere accolto e accettato
Quando ho iniziato la pubertà femminile
lì ho iniziato ad avere un sacco di
dubbi angosce di domande ho iniziato
veramente a sentire la pressione del
genere che mi era stato assegnato
Chi sono io
perché non riesco a trovare persone come
me che cosa ho di diverso
queste domande Mi tormentavano ogni
giorno
allora
ho iniziato a fare un lavoro di
sperimentazione e introspezione che è
durato tantissimi anni e verso i 19 anni
di età ho capito che quello che mi
assillava Veramente era non riuscire ad
esprimere il genere che sentivo mio
quindi quello maschile
verso vent'anni di età avevo scritto una
lettera di coming out rivolte ai miei
genitori Dove appunto gli dicevo che non
era una ragazza che non ero lesbica come
loro pensavano Ma che sono un ragazzo
qua la mia diversità era diventata reale
e concreta Non solo a me stesso ma
davanti a tutti gli altri
un'altra domanda che vi voglio fare è se
sapete come si interagisce con qualcuno
che considerate totalmente differente da
voi
Perché in genere quando le persone
scoprono di me
avvengono due situazioni La prima è
rifiuto che per fortuna avviene molto
raramente ho fortuna Io forse la seconda
è la grande curiosità
il problema della grande curiosità è che
non è sempre apprezzata ci può far
sentire a disagio
Infatti due mesi fa stavo uscendo con
due ragazzi per fare delle conoscenze e
mentre camminavamo ci siamo scambiati il
profilo Instagram da qua a loro hanno
visto tutta la mia vita e subito dopo
hanno iniziato a bombardarmi di domande
ma anche di apprezzamenti che in realtà
non erano dei veri e propri
apprezzamenti
uno di loro
mi aveva detto Ma che strano
come fai ad avere delle spalle così
larghe
oppure per essere un ragazzo trans ha il
viso molto maschile
e io dentro di me mi dicevo ma come Che
strano perché per me questa è
quotidianità Infatti la loro curiosità
stava creando molta più distanza tra me
e loro la curiosità è bella Sì ma se
posto nel modo giusto al contesto giusto
e alle persone giuste
interagire con la diversità è un
esercizio che si impara Aumentando il
proprio senso di empatia e ascoltando
tanto le altre persone perché solo
facendo così riusciamo a capire come
porci cosa possiamo chiedere e domandare
se si parla di relazioni non si può non
parlare di come relazionarsi non si può
non parlare appunto delle relazioni
sessuali affettive amorose perché
comunque le relazioni fanno parte della
vita di ognuno di noi il problema è che
per noi persone trans le relazioni sono
qualcosa di un po' più difficile da
raggiungere
per esempio se una ragazza cisgender e
per cisgender cosa intendo una persona
alla cui alla nascita le hanno assegnato
un determinato genere In questo caso
femminile e questa persona si identifica
in questo genere quindi la maggior parte
di voi se una ragazza cisgender dovesse
iniziare ad avere una relazione
affettiva sessuale con me potrebbe
entrare in contatto con la diversità in
modo più intimo e profondo
in genere le persone si fanno tante
domande Tra cui ma un ragazzo
eterosessuale nel momento in cui
iniziano relazione con una donna trans
è possibile definirlo ancora
eterosessuale oppure come fa una donna
Cheese a provare piacere a letto con un
uomo trans
o come si fa a fare sesso con una
persona di cui non si sa nemmeno che
tipo di genitali abbia
parlare di sesso e sessualità È
importantissimo perché ci dobbiamo
rendere conto che ognuno di noi ha
preferenze e gusti diversi
non abbiamo tutti gli stessi identici
genitali non li usiamo lo stesso modo
e proprio sui genitali vorrei
soffermarmi un attimo perché
una domanda che mi fanno spesso
è ma tu che cosa hai lì sotto
Quali sono i tuoi genitali
e queste domande sono estremamente
violente e rispettose
immaginate voi ora di chiedere alla
persona che avete al vostro fianco che
tipo di genitali abbia
penso che lei inizierebbe a guardarvi
malissimo verreste visti come delle
persone irrispettose anche volgari
però vi posso assicurare che la maggior
parte delle persone si sente in diritto
di fare queste domande
a noi persone trans
quando si parla di genitali di genitali
trans in genere la gente lo fa per
denigrare o invalidare la nostra
identità perché io per la maggior parte
della società non potrei essere
considerato un uomo perché non ho un
pene
un mesetto fa ho voluto creare una
rubrica sui miei Social e quando parlo
di rubrica significa una serie di video
appunto da pubblicare su Instagram Tik
Tok dove parlo dei miei genitori
di come li uso di come sono di come li
percepisco di come me ne prendo cura
Perché Perché non esiste
un'informazione reale e sana in merito
alla sessualità trans
In uno di questi video
racconto del fatto che non tutte le
persone trans vogliono operarsi ai
genitali
Infatti un'altra delle tante domande che
mi fanno riguarda proprio questo cioè ma
tu sei operato
se è completo
l'hai completata la transizione
e a me delle volte viene anche un po' da
ridere perché Che cosa vuol dire sei
completo cioè Esiste un uomo a metà No
non vuol dire niente
io non voglio farla l'operazione ai
genitali
non voglio farla perché non ne sento il
bisogno perché
la mia vulva la sento parte di me della
mia identità
non tutte le persone trans vogliono
farlo
e io vorrei tantissimo che le persone mi
rispettassero a prescindere da cosa ho
lì sotto
perché io sono un uomo
a prescindere dai miei organi genitali
anche senza avere un pene
Infatti io sono un ragazzo
mi chiamo Ethan
e non voglio un pene
Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]